hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Andrew
so today Andrew and I are is I like to
call him Andy I've never called you Andy
in my life you making me feel like a
little kid from Toy Story Toy Story and
also from child's play
thanks man huh I'm like sending you up
to get molested we're gonna check out
the trailer for season two of one of my
all-time favorite shows oh yeah Marvel's
daredevil [ __ ] love the first show
could talk forever about it I'm not
going to I want to clarify something I'm
wearing a Batman beanie right now
because I know how loyal Marvel fans are
and I don't want to upset anyone so I'm
wearing Marvel's most favorite comic
book hero on my head cuz I don't want to
piss anyone off and I know I don't
believe in satire let's do this before
this one batch to batch to batch
Oh father why do I still feel guilty
you're Catholic
the count means your work is not yet
finished downtown office thinks we got a
place in Hell's Kitchen
well they want these offices the
shooters independent which is running
another home turf and taking them out
with military precision
yes now it's hard when I take out half
the city Hell's Kitchen is about to
explode
way to go Netflix
bang people up baby
all of us there's no connection we never
stop to think that Daredevils actions
could open the door for men like this
much longer before as the people start
getting caught astrologer
what is being shed you donated more than
your fair share
this city needs her
I need to take care of the scum that
killed my family
people don't have to die you hit them
and they get back up I hit him in these
stay down
why are you doing this cuz I think
you're a special
I think you're a man who can't finish
the job I think you're a coward
you know you're one bad day with Mimi oh
you like Elektra no she'll be nice
Electra Naches felt it yeah and they
also mentioned her in the parts in
season 1 - ok Punishers voice that's
what we hear beginning of this trailer
first thing people are probably gonna
say sounds like that I know
so because ever since Christian Bale did
that voice anyone else who does a
similar voice just sounds like that man
Rorschach didn't Watchmen anime haven't
compared that if we're gonna talk about
the voice I'm not breaking down Batman
but I feel like a weird thing with a
Batman voice was it didn't quite matches
his face and demeanor it matches with
Jon Bernthal very well as the Punisher
you could see that guy really having
that [ __ ] voice it doesn't seem like
this is a voice he's putting on it's
like that sounds like a real threat
right there yeah not only that but to me
when I hear him and like dude that
sounds like Frank Castle it sounds like
the Punisher exactly I mean I I didn't
mind Thomas Jane and also I think it was
Raya
welcome I prefer a Stevenson Ray
Stevenson and assault he was a mulch tag
and the Thor and also you would need
this so he played to Marvel characters
but I didn't mind their performances
obviously they're the films that were
and weren't amazing or anything just
what I saw in this little clip alone and
this this trailer he looks like he
Justin but it's kind I'm not gonna
compare him to Heath Ledger but just
where like Heath Ledger took over the
wrong like where is he fled right I
don't see him like I don't see Jon
Bernthal all here I'm like dude he is
Frank Castle my question is did Frank
Castle sound like that when he had a
family cuz he would be the scariest
[ __ ] father if he had that voice
while he was raising his family yeah
it's gonna say probably give his kids
nightmares really answer isn't that
voice but I'm sure I mean as I'm sure
like he tones a down loafers family that
I was kind of and I guess you read it
[ __ ] too bad Joe good now there was
something about Frank Castle that seems
relatable the loss of family you know
and it works in comic book characters
but he's a different case because his
family was [ __ ] slaughtered it wasn't
like I lost a parent like that's not
like small but you know his family was
slaughtered and he now he's out for
revenge and it's causing him to be this
like [ __ ] monster you know and that's
what I love about this portrayal of what
we're seeing from the trailer just
instantly you're like this Frank Castle
is not mr. protagonist of the story he
looks like a real antagonist yeah we're
gonna [ __ ] love watching ya know I was
gonna say the way the trailer portrayed
this it looks like he's the villain of
this season kind of like kingpin was
yeah season 1 and only that but like why
you sympathize with Frank Castle like
you said his family was slaughtered you
want him to get revenge on those who did
that to his family like you are feeling
it in your life I love how they're
playing the villain aspect in this
season it's gonna be the banter between
those two characters already like just
looks incredible on your one dead but
what was one your one day away from
becoming one day away from becoming me
such a great life and that's course
that's true because Daredevils [ __ ]
thing is he always wants to kill but he
can't so close to the edge every day no
see the line where he says when you hit
them they they come back up when I hit
them they stay down yeah that's
completely true but Punisher does not
let them get back up because if they're
about to get it back up he puts them
right back down so and that's what makes
a more threatening is because he seems
incredibly skilled they're saying it's
military weapons so you know this guy's
from the military like I know like
anyone who knows Frank Castle knows all
the better I'm just saying what they're
establishing here the fact that the
Punisher is a murderer makes him
incredibly more threatening than
daredevil because daredevil you you
always felt like okay at least he's not
gonna kill them some won't get that bad
right violence in a show like this can
be sometimes scary oh yeah because of
how [ __ ] vile any kids
oh yeah and sure imma like damn how
violent is the show gonna
now that we have someone called The
Punisher right well I mean last season
you know spoilers penguin didn't see
season one someone's head got like
ploughed off by the kingpin when he
slammed the door and so I mean they're
not afraid of new stuff in this show
there wasn't one slam oh no you're
slammed like I'm like yeah yeah it's
really crazy little kill dude this is
connected to the MCU and like this is
the most violent take on the MTU I've
ever seen and I love it
and what I love about these shows too
they don't need to explain everything in
two hours they get 14 hours for 13 or 14
episodes to explain and go into the
story that's why I love kingpin lat last
season we got to go into his backstory
there's no way we could have done that
in a two-and-a-half-hour film or
two-hour film
get into all that stuff I let that's why
I like sometimes how they separate the
MCU and I love last year all the
connections they made the MCU buy the
references to the battle new york so you
know they don't go out of their way to
say we're connected but they're super so
they're super sadly exactly it's not
obnoxious everyone just seems like they
have badass dialogic like when the
priest is like your work is not yet
finished everyone sounds like this but
the priest I've always liked the
interaction because that can be a very
big cliche in a lot of work of movies
and shows you know the guy who's always
confessing to the same priest what's
cool about this priests is you know he
knows he's daredevil he's not gonna say
it more like a father figure I feel like
- you know this guy kind of steers him
in the right direction I like the theme
of what they're doing with Jericho
that's why I met by Dark Knight
similarity you know like maybe the
reason someone like The Punisher exists
is because the daredevil opened the door
for that same thing as like what they
talked about with the Joker's that man
has created a door for someone like the
Joker to shine I like seeing that
because it does make daredevil more
personally involved because of the fact
that if we know the Frank Castle story
it's not because of daredevil however I
can see why daredevil takes such a
responsibility to end this guy I think
they have confirmed that the Punisher is
going to get his own Netflix show and I
love that they infused him yeah I love
the thing fused him in this first more
isn't antagonist more as a daredevil
kind of created this guy even though you
know we know the backs are if he his
family got slaughtered so that's why you
kind of does what he does but I think
it's also they're setting up that
I mean obviously they're setting up that
daredevil created this guy but also
they're setting up that Punisher puts
guys down because daredevil won't do the
right thing in his mind he allows these
creeps to get back up and they murder
people like they murders yeah so I love
that theme that they're going when I
love dialogue back and forth when it's a
clash of morality yeah Brenner knowing
the riders and knowing the two [ __ ]
actors they have doing it just know
those scenes of just interaction are
gonna be some of the best scenes yeah
beyond the fights beyond the adventure
those will be the most intense
I agree no I feel like this year 2016 is
the year of superheroes clashing against
each other we got punished reversed
daredevil we got Captain America vs iron
man we got Batman V Superman damn title
made me say V I love how we're getting
this backstory and then it's leading
into the series make him popular in this
series again and then give him his own
series and I it's just very smart
marketing to me looking at the Moret of
morale tale here I love good conflict to
the point where I as an audience member
and finding myself sometimes siding with
daredevil and sometimes signing with
Punisher yeah I like to be thrown back
and forth I'm hoping it's not black and
white where you're like a little clearly
Punisher is wrong it will create [ __ ]
people talking about it too and that's
the fun part is when you have those
discussions I love how they didn't
[ __ ] should really show much of
Elektra because off the t's I could give
I love that they're building her up in a
smarter way because they're letting her
be more secretive it doesn't feel like
there jamm packing this season I feel
like Elektra might even get more focus
in season 3 then she will get in season
2 I like that though I like that they're
taking their time and Marvel has is
interesting in it they have this
interesting rep for not producing the
some of the greatest villains they
always have they're known to have like
mediocre villains but if you look at
daredevil season 1 you look at Jessica
Jones now you look at this they know
what they're doing with their
antagonists
this shows yeah I'm so [ __ ] respect
the characters they respect the lore and
then again just it's very like like we
said the writing in the show is just
crisp it's amazing it's just just a
little dialogue we're hearing it in this
trailer is phenomenal what I'm really
interested in seeing - um it's not Bucky
that's from Winter Soldier what's his
name the buddy his sy his partner but
Matt Murdock's partner man
oh uh honey foggy foggy foggy Nelson
yeah these people actually portrayed by
John found out for Avro in the movie
right foggy was an interesting person
for me because I didn't always give a
[ __ ] about like there were times where
it's like I was really not interested at
all in his story I thought things got
more interesting - especially when he
found out that Matt is daredevil for
sure I'm really hoping they amplify that
relationship in that arena as opposed to
he just becomes his sidekick who gets
along with him now you know like yeah
his buddy is willing to help him out and
support him I want some conflict between
those guys and I feel like you get a
tease of that woman you know something
about bloodshed what he's talking about
but I want to see some tension I want to
see some issues like that this is real
situations are you act like if I found
out that you were fighting crime I'd say
that's sick is crap and all but be
careful as hell you know I don't feel
fear for your life a little bit
imagine when Marvel finally puts
daredevil and Batman their favorite
Marvel character in the same I can't
wait to move that move it and lastly I
want to say I hope they bring kingpin
back in some way oh they have to make it
you can't just leave him in jail me and
he's staring at that wall we need to
find out what else is going on I'm glad
I didn't kill him off oh okay yeah they
did I was thinking that I was literally
like I read that [ __ ] yeah no I agree no
to me like you said earlier he's
probably my top three favorite MCU
villains I say there's Loki I guess
Winter Soldier you can make an argument
that he's an antihero because Hydra
brainwash him but still for that film I
felt he was so scary and I felt he
wasn't for that particular film he's a
villain in that film until you know you
get the idea Buffy and then the kingpin
he Wilson Fisk he's so menacing and you
feel so much sense of danger for Matt
anytime he's on screen it doesn't matter
whether they're on-screen together
whether there are a few miles away in
the distance
you felt so much tension and danger
format whenever Wilson Fisk's with on so
they better bring him back and that is
our trailer review listen guys keep a
lookout we're probably going to do a
review he'll probably do a review on his
channel movie source for daredevil
season 2 I'm definitely gonna do at
least the pilot review and then probably
a finale review so keep a lookout for
that when the show is released if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe
today become a reject man like to reject
those kids in hell yeah they're having
fun playing soccer out there and what
are [ __ ] little place saudara under a
seal on on street food lovest manic kids
just not those asthmatic kids there's no
reason for therus panic I'm doing it
anyway subscribe to the channel
Andrew twitter.com slash egg or 7-eleven
movie source channel check it out I'm
gonna be doing a film analysis review
with him of the Deadpool movie on one
day I'm gonna film that with him don't
know when we'll be out but keep a
lookout for that - and follow me on
Instagram Twitter vine lamp promoting
yourself is so much work